i have long believed that we were in a
dark age
i
were in a
a cryptic dark age that one was dawning
i have my own set of terminology
surrounding this uh
i call i i would argue that every dark
age has people who continue
to
do science
that they can be very obscure often
times their entire product is probably
lost to history
i call these keepers of the flame
and so there's that
but in any case the degree to which
science has been unhooked by
market forces and replaced by things
that you know basically cargo cult
science to use feynman's terminology for
it is extreme it has grown even much
more extreme than when i started
thinking about this but when i ran into
your work and i found that a i'm not the
only person on earth who thinks that
dark age is not too strong a term but b
what really surprised me about your your
work
was how long into the past you believe
that process has been going on you you
put the start date of our dark age
way earlier than i would have even
thought
to place it and so let's talk a little
bit about why you think we're in a dark
age and why you when you think it
started
what changed and uh
you know why so early
the the first part of the question the
reason i think we're in a dark age is
because i have
taken seriously people's claims in a
bunch of different domains and ask and
keep asking them questions why they
believe what they believe because i find
their conclusions very unintuitive and
i'm trying to learn
and i found that a lot of times they're
appealing to
ideas that seem highly dubious
and
they find their origins in the first
part of the 20th century across
disciplines so i'm i'm trying to make
sense of some spectacular claims i'm
sure you've heard people
make some
incredible claim about reality and they
say well as we learn from quantum
mechanics things can be in a mutually
exclusive state at the same time
what does that mean that's a shocking
claim so you look into it and you look
into me go okay well there's this thing
called the copenhagen interpretation
that was established blah blah blah
same thing happens in mathematics i
don't know if you know
how familiar are with some of these
concepts but there's this notion of the
infinite set in mathematics
the idea that there is a set of numbers
which is infinite in size that there are
infinitary processes that can be
completed
it's a shocking claim interesting so you
investigate investigate you find okay a
lot of these ideas were established the
same general time period and so i
started to see
patterns of really bad ideas at present
seeming to have their origins at around
the same time period i'm going to put it
somewhere around 1880
to somewhere around 1950. a lot was
happening at that time so in terms of
ideas uh i for me this may be incorrect
i might there's there's one exception
where this might the story might go back
further but let's just say it starts at
roughly 1880 1880. the reason we had a
bunch of uh
bad ideas established around then is
because for the previous
few thousand years
our mathematics was more or less built
on concepts that came from euclidean
geometry
and
it was fashionable to think a lot of
people have thought throughout history
that euclidean geometry was
was the same thing as geometry there is
one geometry it is euclidean geometry
and
why uh um our advanced mathematical
ideas get their justification through
euclidean geometry well what happened
around this time period was the
development of non-euclidean geometries
which a lot of people said okay well if
there are non-euclidean geometries what
actually is the foundations of math we
assumed it was euclidean geometry which
is based in self-evident principles
self-evident axioms that anybody can
use and discover and see why the
conclusions follow but
if there are non-euclidean geometries
maybe
we need a different foundation for math
so there was a this is not just my
opinion
there was a let's call it a formal
academic crisis around the foundations
of mathematics that was taking place
roughly from yeah 1880 to like the 19
yeah through the 1940s i think is fair
to say
now a lot of those conversations weren't
ended correctly like the the questions
weren't answered
you know people asking the questions
sort of died out they had different
schools of thought the school of thought
that wound up winning
didn't have good philosophical answers
and in fact in practice was kind of
anti-philosophical said stop asking the
questions and then we don't have
problems finding answers
something very similar happened in
physics
where you had a revolution in
multiple revolutions at the beginning of
the 20th century you had the development
of relativity which was which is a
mind-blowing idea to think that gravity
is
something that comes from the structure
of space-time
what the heck that means that's that's a
shocking idea and then shortly after
that you have the development of quantum
mechanics which
among other things one interpretation of
quantum mechanics called the copenhagen
interpretation says that there is no
such thing as a observation independent
reality
observation slash measurement
independent reality so we can't talk
about nature in some state outside of
what is being measured that's a shocking
claim if that's true that is an
absolutely mind-blowing claim
and i think it turns out to be false
and
and so
if you
have deep conversations with people who
have
sometimes wild sounding ideas you would
be shocked to find how many of their
wild ideas are somehow justified in
uh either
the physics and the copenhagen
interpretation oh reality is
contradictory so therefore i can be
contradictory or even in concepts in
mathematics
now i have had multiple conversations
recorded on my podcast with professors
going around uh trying to root out the
source of a lot of these bad ideas
and i have had people tell me on my show
that they've given me examples of
existent logical contradictions
uh
one of them was uh the infinite set
this i i spoke with a philosopher at
columbia or i was a philosopher of
mathematics and he's and we were talking
about whether or not there could be
logical contradictions because that's a
shocking claim if there are and he said
oh yeah there are logical contradictions
like for example the infinite sense kind
of a logical contradiction now he was
saying the infinite set is a
contradictory concept in defense of it
which is an interesting position to take
i was just mind blown that that somebody
would say that with a straight face
there was in fact a whole school of
thoughts
called the dilethius school which says
there are actually existent logical
contradictions uh you can there's a
couple examples like the liars paradox
this sentence is false the way that they
try to handle the liar's paradox is by
saying it is true and false at the same
time whatever that means so sort of
explode logic to try to defend uh the
existence of a real paradox so anyway
i'm i'm examined i'm examining bad ideas
and i find myself
i keep coming to people keep appealing
to the ideas that were established
around the turn of 20th century
so and then i look at those ideas and i
go okay well there were there was some
prominent people
that came up with copenhagen
interpretation yields bore for example
there were some notable dissidents
uh einstein would be an example of
somebody who's notorious for rejecting
some of the more wild implications of
copenhagen interpretation and einstein
made better arguments but neil's bore
one out
so the same thing happened in uh in
mathematics around the same time you had
different schools of thought the
logistics the formula the formalists and
the intuitionists formalists went out
but better ideas in my estimation were
were made by the other schools the
logistics who said that mathematics is
an extension of logic that's where
mathematical truth comes from is logic
the intuition it said well there is not
necessarily objective truth in
mathematics mathematics is all
constructed in the mind the objects of
mathematics are objects in our mind and
i think there's they have some aspect of
the truth but anyway the the worst
position of all was the formalist and
they said listen
what we have to do is explicitly strip
meaning out of mathematics
we have powerful structures of math that
allow us to
explain something in the world we can
use the math we can apply the math but
when you start asking the philosophical
questions we don't have we run into
paradoxes so stop asking them
so i see that as well that's a very big
problem now you also had in the early
20th century you had
economic and political revolutions at
the same time so you had you know
communist revolutions you had in that
time period in that 70 years you had two
world wars that was sort of uh you know
world defining world shaping you had the
establishment you know the latter half
the at the 19th century you had you know
the germ theory of disease was taking
off what was was being developed um you
had keynesianism was in the 1930s like i
said so the reason i'm
i am
seeing that
my best explanation for the dark age
that we're in when you
if you were to peer into the mind of the
believers of really bad ideas that seem
to say really silly things all the time
and you were to try to figure out where
those ideas come from
i'm seeing tons of connections to that
70-year time period from 1880 to 1950
where it was tumultuous intellectually
as well as you know historically and
politically electrification was
happening you know there's a lot going
on then
okay so that's the that's the version
yeah i think you've put some things
together for me that i did not
understand and they've
touched on another set of concepts i
didn't realize was nearby
so heather and i were professors for 15
years
and we became quite compelled that one
of the biggest obstacles to successful
education
was
the remoteness
of
physical reality
to students and in specific we started
assigning students
to teach themselves things
where success or failure was unambiguous
and did not require anyone to tell you
whether you had succeeded or failed
right in other words if you set out to
build a tower and it falls down you
can't pretend you know you could lie to
yourself i guess but the point is it's
obvious it fell down if you're trying to
fix an engine and it doesn't start you
didn't fix it
so
the reason that that's important is that
in an environment where everything is
socially mediated where you know that
you understood the biology because the
person at the front of the room who is
the biologist told you you understood it
right that's very risky because if the
person at the front of the room doesn't
understand biology themselves then
you'll you'll do
more harm in learning what they think
than if you learn nothing right so
here's the question
our technology
progresses
to the point
that what we think we understand is no
longer checkable
by very many people
right
i haven't looked deeply into the
machinery
of
cells physically right i've seen major
organelles but i can't do very much to
check all of the things that i'm told
about cellular biology i have to take
the cellular biologist word for it
and my point is not that they're wrong
i'm sure they're wrong in some ways i'm
sure they're right in other ways
but the point is
once you're looking at things that are
sufficiently small that you need
high-tech
mechanisms to allow you any insight into
what's there at all you're now running
new risks that what you're being told is
true isn't true and that your intuition
that can't be true because it's not what
i've seen you know when i've looked into
cells i haven't seen that process well
you haven't looked into cells right so i
guess the question is is is the thing
that you're detecting that early date
the result of the fact that across
discipline after discipline we crossed a
threshold where it was impossible for
most of the people in the discipline to
assess for themselves is this cur is
this descartes nightmare
i think this is a small part of it okay
the reason i say that is because the
when you actually engage with the ideas
that were being discussed even if
they're abstract ideas
in some circumstances you don't need the
empirical verification i think what
you're saying is critically important
for uh
even making predictions if you can find
a discipline which is more connected to
real world feedback you are going to
find a discipline that has better
quality ideas than one which has no real
real real world feedback this is true
also in the martial arts it's true
everywhere um but
when i look at the
debate between
niels bohr
and einstein
i don't see something that can only be
resolved empirically
there are there are there are trivial
conceptual errors that are that are made
that still did not seem to change the
the social influence let's say of the
the wielders of the bad ideas
i'm not
i think i'm making a slightly more
subtle point than that okay it's not
it's again a taking the safety off the
gun issue it's not that as soon as
people can't check
that the rate of errors goes way up
it's that as soon as people can't check
the likelihood of important errors being
caught goes down and the degree to which
a persuasive person who is incorrect
continues to have influence goes up
and so i guess the point is
nature bats last
the world
is the arbiter of whether a scientific
or the universe is the arbiter of
whether a scientific idea is correct or
not based on predictive power of that
concept
and the degree to which we are taking
people's word for what has been
established or falsified
is now
um
overwhelming
that is definitely going on
but i'll i'll still i'll still push back
here so in the in the what you've just
articulated
it sounds like you would say correct me
if i'm wrong because maybe this is where
we have a disagreement it sounds like
you would say something like
if reality if if a empirical experiment
could
demonstrate
that
one idea is a lot better than another
idea
that
that is sufficient to have the better
idea when out in the short run
um
you know there's a lot built into
what exactly we're using but you know
in the long run
predictive power is
the only tool
we have
for assessing the relative merit of
competing ideas in the short run though
because because in the in the grand
scheme of things we're type we're
talking about you know the 20th century
this is the short run it sounds like
it sounds like what you're saying is if
uh
if we
had
a way to
simply test whether or not a particular
theory was true or false that that would
itself
solve a lot of these problems because
the assumption is
the academics would
recognize when a idea has been
invalidated
no i'm saying geez i don't know how to
convey it but imagine for a second that
there was a planet
that you were going to become expert you
and 50 other students were going to
become expert
on
the
social goings-on on a planet that you
couldn't visit or watch directly
and basically how were you going to
become expert on this well different
people who had been there
were going to come into the room and
they were going to tell you what they'd
seen and you were going to build a model
of the behavior of the creatures on this
other planet based on their observations
and my point is if you would directly
observe that planet i came in who is a
fool
you might detect actually you know what
i really that's not what i saw i think
that person i'm not gonna
put a big asterisk on everything that
person says because i'm not sure they
know what they're doing right but
in this other landscape you might think
well that person has the fancier degree
the longer publication record um they
speak more persuasively and so the point
is the errors that get in
stick at a level that they should not so
it's something like
the facts of the experience
of one practitioner
are not then experienced by another
right and i
look i'm not a philosopher but my
understanding is this is kind of what
drove descartes crazy was when he
realized that um the fraction of what he
was supposedly what he fractured the
fraction of what he knew
that he was taking on someone else's
authority the danger was immense now
maybe the danger wasn't as big as he
thought because the number of things
that have to be true for lots of people
who have done the work to be wrong
simultaneously
you know it's unlikely but then it
becomes true at the beginning of the
20th century when we're dealing with
things that
require high technology to detect
and so you see
i think that is part of it but but the
the aspect that i would emphasize
is
that
it is it is not the case that it would
take
sophisticated equipment and technology
to figure out that a lot of these
paradigmatic ideas are wrong oh i
totally agree with this and this is the
thing i don't
get when you do look at these ideas and
you discover you know look in my field
right the idea
that there is only one species
per niche that two species cannot stably
co-exist in a niche
indefinitely one is always superior
competitively and it's driving the
inferior one to extinction right i get
how you could see that if you live in
the temperate zone nobody who's been to
the tropics could believe that and it's
unfalsifiable because
to the extent that you have 300 trees
doing approximately the same thing in
the same place you can always argue that
well they are competitively distinct as
saplings or blah blah blah anyway it's a
wrong idea that persists because it sort
of sounds intuitively like it ought to
be true and people haven't spotted why
it's false
um
it's not
that any biologist is unaware of the
number of species of tree doing
identical things on the mainland
tropical forest it's that they don't
trust
their own understanding well enough to
call [ __ ] okay that that is big
i don't exactly know what's going on
there but that
is a pattern that is across disciplines
and it's weird because some of these
ideas are
in the open spoken about
explicitly and yet there's a disconnect
between
a recognition of an idea being wrong and
a changing of the theory or the culture
around that idea and i don't understand
what's going on there but i've seen it a
bunch of times
[Music]